Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to "Deepeo!" (Diep.io)
Or "Dye-epp-io." Or I'm not 100% sure WHAT it's called, because i dont get any of the names of these games correctly,
Considering "Ah-gar-ee-oh" (Agar.io) and "Slih-there-ee-oh" (Slither.io) aren't the actual names of those games.
BUT I'm gonna call it "Deep-ee-oh!" 'Cause I got nothin' else to do with my life.
And, this game has been unbelievably, like, UNBELIEVABLY requested. Every single- ah!
MG Fire's crawlin' up my ass already!  Every single, uh, social media that I have has been inundated with requests for this game.
And so, this game is actually relatively simple, but in the same Agar.io and Slither.io stylings,
you're basically on a grid and you're a little dude amongst a sea of other dudes.
But in this one, it's different, because you're a tank in this one, and it's got a really interesting upgrade system
where you're trying to kill both other players and these boxes here.
Uh, which, I dunno what they represent, other than just, like, normal resources that you have to blow up.
I'm assuming this is America simulator because you just gotta blow up everything to progress in the world.
AHH! Don't kill me!
And there's other players, and as you upgrade throughout the game, uuuh, you get various different branching options with which you can play the game
Like, right now I just got the basic stuff, and I'm gonna upgrade... bullet damage and speed if you notice in bottom left you got alot of upgrade options over there
And the various size, shapes, and color... crap... are the various different amount of points you get by, and the quicklier you get points you can more level up
Blah blah blah! But, what the more important thing is, that, when you get to about level- *Scared markiplier noises*
When you get to about Level 20, *scared noise*
There's some higher level people that are creepin' around, and you just gotta play it safe and try not to bother anybody before you just die a HORRIBLE DEATH!
Ah, God!!
Dolan! Don't do it! I won't mess with you, you won't mess with me, c'mon.
You can also shoot b-ohhh fuck me!
*scared singing* Ohhh God! Ehh, lemme get my health up! Oh God! I'monna die.
See? Okay, but if you see, over here, I now have twin guns! and i'm going with twin guns because before I tried the machine gun path
and then I got to this cannon thing that didn't work out too well for me. it did make me go pretty fast around
but that's getting too deep into the strategems about this game instead of getting into something that *weird deep voice* I can actually control!
*inhale* WHICH IS NOTHING!!!
NOTHING AT ALL!
Anyway.
Ohhh, s--I'm so sorry, Ariel, you have to --
Oh you're... you're... you're not... here. you were you're you were...spawning... I guess, and I was trying to kill you like an idiot.
As you get your upgrades going, you'll notice that your guns shoot much better more and do the thing better,
and this one's actually pretty good! Hot damn, it's like the machine gun but I got two barrels!
It's even better than the machine gun that I had before! HOORAY! HOORAY for upgrades! :D I'm Double Dick Rick! 8==D  8==D
Blastin' my way through uh... *reluctantly* "Deepeo!" I dunno.
I dunno what it's called.
Why is that guy just named SSSS? Well he's dead now *laughing* so i cant exactly ask him.
Alright, anyway, so now that I got my, uh, bullet damage AND reload up, i'm going to be huh hopefully upgra*sort of singing?*ADING SOME MORE STUFF AND NOT DIEING A HORRIBLE DEATH
That would be ideal.
AAAAH it's a machine gunner! That guy's a machine gunner.
And i-HOH! AAHHH I'm surrounded by death! I'm surrounded by every type of death!
*scared noise*
Thank you li'l guy. That li'l guy was tryin' to be advantageous about his circumstance but it...worked out for me better than worked out for hiiim
It's just so easy to die in this game! But what's good about it is that, uh, when you do die, you actually spawn again at half your le-
Holy shit that guy.
*scared noise* That guy! *another scared noise*
I gotta get my bullet speed up because... i'm not able to chase anybody down with my bullets or-
I-I-It's a really effective deterrent just to blast someone with a spray of bullets *weird voice* the likes of which they've never seen
Poor babsy-boo go blasted apart!
And then... on the leaderboard -- man, Link is waay too high-score.
But the other good thing is there's a max level that you can reach. (45)
so there's sort of, like, uh, a limit to how far you can progress,
so that makes it so that some people aren't just absolutely unbeatable.
And also, I've noticed that the more bullets you shoot, the slower you go-oOoO,
you dont wanna mess with me bruh.
I got... I got -- why are you shootin' so slow?
What's wrong with that guy? I don't know, everything probably.
He's probably just luring me in with a false sense of security before he annihilated me.
Well I seem to be annihilating him.
so I'm not- I'mma leave him alone for now. Maybe we're buddies. maybe- maybe- maybe baby we're buddies
I have no idea a hundred percent...
*grunt* Okay, so I'm gonna get my movement speed up
because I need to be able to dodge. *weird voice*ooh it's you!
It's you Nelsoniux!
C'mere baby!  Ah he's got way more faster speed than I.
But if you shoot in the opposite direction
you'll actually go faster which is kind of an interesting strategem
because it allows you to both run away from the people that you're trying to not die from
and then also, it allows you to kinda weirdly push yourselves toward people if you
fire in the opposite direction.
it's very bizarre, and like a combination of different elements coming together is kind of a nice... little bit of...what- what you might call strategy.
but I don't have none of that- NELSON! You're cool in my book.
Let's just take the little *gasping* the little baby tanks that we just murdered
and take their points and run away! Forever and ever!
And never meet each other again... oh...oh god...
I imagine this one's also gonna get mods soon to get sound effects and whatnot I- I-
I feel like this one needs a bit more stressful sound effects or at least epic battle music going on.
because you're actually a tank that's blowing pe -
*gasps* OOOOH!!! *excitedly* I can be Triple Dick Rick! *laughing* I can be- uuum trip- triple- Triple Shlong John! da- *Grunts* I can- I can be Triple Penis Enis
I'm gonna be Triple Penis Enis. 8==D 8==D 8==D
Ohh.. *laughing* is this better? I dont know if this is better. I liked it better before, I could actually concentrate the things that I was shooting at
Oh, this is...this isn't....
Sometimes, like, this is what happened before, while I was doin' the machine gun!
The machine gun was g--oh, I'm so slohohohoow, oh my god!
AHH, this is horrible!
Why did I choose this!?
I can--I can, like street-sweep the items. That's good. I'll get a lot of points that way.
I wasn't gonna get a lot of points from killing anybody anyway, so why would I bother with anything else?
Alright, so I got three upgrades, I'm just kinda *slightly angrily* mmhhhh...
Just kinda *angrily* MMHHH.
Just kinda *more angrily* MMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM--
Sorry!!
Excuse my spray, everybody!
Excuse the spray from Triple Penis Enis, comin' through! 8==D 8==D 8==D
I just wanna be a wall of death!
Anything that approaches me rapidly rethinks its choices in life.
That's--that's the only thing that I want.
It's the only thing that I need.
Also, you can see, I'm just passing the leader on the left there, he's goin' over there--
There is a baaattle goin' on here.
I'm just tryin' to shoot the bullets that are comin' my way!
It's actually a pretty effective deterrant!  I mean if no one sneaks up behind me and stabs me in the butt
I think I'll be relatively okay.
But, I actually--I actually like this game a lot. It allows for a lot of strategy and individual play
Uhh, which is good... tokyo ghoul, are you just... are you just...  is he just- is he just?
Welp! I got him! I guess I got a lotta points outta that!
He was just sittin' around, waitin' for death!
That's the only thing that I need in my life.
Just people to take advantage of before the end...
Okay.  I need...
Last bit of bullet damage, I'm gonna max my health out so I'm TOUGH as ROCK.
And then...I believe there's only five levels after this, so I probably gonna max out movement speed and then *inhales*
Hope for the best from there, 'cause Link is still top dawg!
BUT I'M ON THE LEADERBOARD BABY!
Yeeeah!
I'm on the Leaderboard--I'm only number ten, but I'm okay!
That's okay in my book! I'm just gonna get away from this leader.
If I just shoot backwards, I'm totally okay!
I go super fast! No one mind me!
weee~
It's--if I just create, like, a box...
I-it's really fun, because every person is their own bullet hell.
Like, the--i-i-it's just a non-stop bullet hell of various players goin' about.
And then they're just having fun trying to dodge everybody's bullets.
It works out quite nicely.  I think that guy's a sniperrr....
Oh, RAKE!  Oh, I've played many a Rake games.
You don't wanna mess with me!
The good thing about this is my bullets do so much damage that they actually knock
other people's bullets outta the airrr...
Competition is gettin' kinda fierce.
I need-I need these.
I-I need these... items... for stuff and... things.
I did see one ti--whoa, hey whoa-whoaa!
Ow.  Ow!  OW!
OWW!
Geezums, who was that?
THE MARKIFARK LIV--the-M-plpphh
THE MARKIFART LIVES ON.
Oh my god! What is with that guy?
Holy shit!
When do I get an upgrade like that?
Aww, I'm just stuck on Triple Penis Enis.
I wanna be back to Double Dick Rick!
Ohh... Euhhh!  Maybe even more dongs.
More dongs like I don't know--oh, god.
This is a bad situation.
Bad situation! Bad situat--ohh my god!  Someone's a good shot!
Not this guy. Obviously.
Ahh, go backwards! AHH! NO!
OH GOD! I DON'T WANNA DIE!
Ah, I've got so much to live for!  I've got so many things to do with my triple penis!
AHH I've got no health regen!
I was stupid! I made bad choices!
I tried to be master of a few instead of master of a loooot!
Euhhh, just run away!
Just beware my SPRAY.
Oh god! That is too many bullets!
That's an unfair amount of bullets!
That is literally waaay too many bullets--I went to the competition area...
I didn't even realize that I was- oh god I--I'm gonna get health regen but it's not gonna do me any good.
AHH! Ooh--ooh, dodge--dodge 'em! Dodge 'em! MMHHH dodge 'em!
MMMMHHH dodge 'em! MMdodge! Dodge. Ooh, dodge.
Ooh, dodgey-dodge. Ooooh, dodge-a-lodge.
Ooh... yeh... Yeh. Yech.
PICK ON THE LITTLE GUYS AND DODGE.
PICK OFF THE LITTLE GUYS AND DO--Oh, fuck you, Sniper Buh.
Bruh! Breh! You wanna come at me BREH?
You wanna come at Triple Penis Enis??
MEH FUCK YOU *voice crack* BREH!
Fuck you *purposeful voice crack?* BREHEH!!
Fugyuu *definate purposeful voice crack* BREHEHHH!
AHHAHH TOO MANY BULLETS BREH!
AHH TOO MANY BULLETS! Okay. We're fine.
Everything's totally fi--No. No, don't do it, marvin!
Marvin, marvin, marvin--marvin, marvin, c'mon!
C'mon, marvin. C'mon. C'mon. Please. Don't be this way.
Don't be this way, Marv!
MARV! Oh god, who's doin' that?
Shit. Euhh. I just gotta get... outta- AAAH! MARV NO!
MAAAHHH-OOO!
So, the good thing about when you die is that you actually spawn in ha-half your level,
so you're not just totally done, and actually if you get high enough you can actually start at a rank-
Ohh, I need to get up quick- Okay, reload.
I'm gonna go for movement speed this time.
And then... health regen... I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go twin again, but I'm not gonna go Triple Penis Enis, because that was just... It was just...
It was ju- It was too much to handle, I ca- I can't handle all that responsibility, if you know what I mean.
You don't know what I mean? Oh, okay, well I'll just...
I'll keep... I'll keep blaspheming over here in the corner, don't mind me.
Don't mind me!
*cough* It's a Let's Play corner up in the top left, don't worry about it...
S'totally cool...
What, did I not upgrade my bullet damage at all?  Really?
Did I not do that? I must not have upgraded my d-
I did not upgrade my damage at all. Why didn't I do that?
That was, like, super important for me to upgrade.
'Cause I can't actually get any points out of it, if I can't actually kill anything.
But I'm fast!
*Lisping* So I guess that's, consolations prizes are cool too, I guess, you know...
Whaatever...
Ah, it's Jish!  Oh, everyone's going for twin gunners, apparently.
Apparently that's the cool thing to be...
*anime voice* Hehhheheheh, you've activated my Trap Card!
Good thing I don't actually do much damage, or else that woulda been dangerous for ya!
*high pitch guttural* OOOOHHhhhh!
*guttural* OHH!
What're you gonna do, huh?
*high-pitched* weeee~!
Boingety-boingety-boingety-boingety-boingety.
AHH!  WHAT the--OH!
He led me-- He had body damage!
OH SHIT.
OHHH GOD!
Aw, shit, I gotta start over at the beginning again.
Okay, I'm just gonna go... damage and reload, 'cause...
Oh, fuck i--fuck this, fuck this, fuck this breh!
AHH, I STARTED OUT SO GOOD!
I'M ENDING SO TERRIBLY!
I'M GOING DOWN IN FLAMES!
I don't have any sassy jokes to save me from this!
OHH MAN! AHH GOD!
Ahh, shit.
I...I-I had it, and I-I didn't have it, I lost it, I went for... I j-th-th-j-th-th....
The moral of the story is: Never go for Triple Penis Enis! It'll never work out for ya.
It's just... it's not worth the risk.
If ya know what I mean.
Alright, I'm gonna go for Sniper, 'cause why not?
OH YES, THIS IS GOOD, I LIKE THAT!
Oh, nice and sloohohohow!
But I can see more!  So that's good!
I mean, I guess!
Oh, shit, hello. What the fuck are you?
I dunno what those are.
*weird voice* Euhh! Eugh, but I'm a Sniper!
Oh God, I can see ya!
Oh God! Don't do it!
Don't do it, breh... *laughing* I'm just a weak little Markifart...
*crying* Let the Markifart live... for one more day!
Ohhh... Sweet, delicious life.
That's right, back off! You can't beat me!
Well, you probably could, if you'd've pressed your advantage.
But you won't be pressing nothing against me!
Shwa! Sniper's actually pretty cool, I will admit.
Sniper's actually not bad. Sniper's not the worst I've ever seen.
'Cause Sniper... allows me to...
One: See more. And Two: Make precision strikes.
So, if I'm good at what I do...
Which I'm not...
I can... *slowly* get some kiiiills...
Which I wooon't.
Nice.
That's an interesting strategy, though. Going for body damaging, because people wouldn't see it coming.
If you got enough bullets to block their bullets, but just to get closer, and a lot of movement speed...
You could probably do a lot of damage to someone and they would never know what hit 'em. Like...
Like, like what happened to me. I never even thought about that as a strategy.
The melee class in-in Diep.io.
*markiplier noises* AH-eh-eh-egh-ugugh-ahghoily--UGHUH--
*weird voice* Uh, you don't wanna mess wi' me bruh!
You don't WANNA mess wi' me!!
Whoa shit, I don't wanna mess wi' him.
Ah. Ah! AH! AHH!
AAoookay. Alright.
Aaehh, that's all the time I got for this episode of Diep.io.
I'm gonna start out... on a new server.
And hopefully...
it'll work out better for me, because I had it in the beginning! I did-I perf--
I performed high in the beginning, and then I just saaailed downwards into the...
Depths of stupidity, which is where I usually end up in all my Let's Plays, so...
THANK you, everybody, so much for watching!
You can play this game for yourself in the comments--er-ER-EHRR-- *the wild markiplier.exe has faced an error*
In the DESCRIPTION below.
There's a link down there, it's really fun. Totally free, like the other ones.
And just an enjoyable time, so... THANK you, everybody, so much for watching.
And, as always, I will see YOU... in the next video!
Bye-bye! =D
*Crazy la Paint outro*
YES! Burry! Suck it, Burry!
Yeah, you were number one on the leaderboard, now you're number one on the suck board--
Yeah, you're gonna get it now!  I'm gonn-AWWWHH!!!
What a buncha bull-ass!
Do do do doooo...
NEXT?: http://store.steampowered.com/app/329130